then you go to park once again
immaculate voice but
what park had i think
was a way of touching us
on all of our emotions
and especially on
like park had the power to infuse
your emotional thought like brenda has a
baby dear mama
but then he had the power to arouse
your the rebel in you
you know yeah and those two things
uh
actually
he's he was probably more dangerous
uh
than big no no choice b.i.g like
notorious b.i.g we could party with him
to this day we were still
but park was probably going to a point
you know he was more
going into the malcolm x of things and
yeah and and and society fears that
yeah so he was really good at
communicating love and and and at
starting revolutions yeah
yeah and that's dangerous very dangerous
and they communicated love but he wasn't
starring revolutions
well it's it's interesting to think
about what the world would be like if
they were still with us
but
it's the way the world hendrix
a lot of those guys just go too too soon
yes it's a peculiar thing you know so
now you asked me earlier
am i scared of death
um
and i answered you know not scared of
death i mean i'm not trying to see it
though you know i mean yeah it's like
that was the block of death
it's like i'm not really going right
there right now i'm making a left for a
right turn
you know i mean unless it was mandatory
for
some greaterness greater good it's like
okay i gotta drive through that
you know yeah but it can still happen
that's the meditation on death part
where you could die at the end of today
yeah you could die or death well dying
and death i think is two different
things
personally um the process you mean of
death or just yeah i mean you could die
i guess you could die every day
you could die and not be yourself
you know what i mean
which is crazy
but to get to a point of no return
you know that's a whole other chamber
i mean there's some sense in which
reza the
producer
becomes somebody else completely when
you're making a film becomes somebody
else completely when you're um
i don't know playing chess becomes
completely something different when you
uh do kung fu
or watch kung fu or when you're a family
man all of those are little deaths when
you transition from one place to another
so it's not like you're one being you're
you're many things
yeah
i would describe now i would describe
that it's all life though
you